by Romanov who Nets off for Washington
slings on varlamov who got the blocker
up in the nick of time Carlson straight away ketza
holding Dylan stro operating next Carlson long
wrer gloved by varlamov he didn't squeeze it
though of Zone time for this Cap's power play
so far keep it on the perimeter stro settles
hesitates finds Wilson for a blast blocked
away working to the outside with sandine
snapshot coming rejected by varlamov another
patch save rebound to the doorstep varlamov
anchors that before oetkin could tuck it in Alex
oetkin finds Phillips back for sandine Maneuvers
around Holstrom as we return to five on five play
six minutes minutes into the contest Phillips is
lurking behind the net leier snapshot gloved by
varlam off there's no rebound of course I'm ready
to compete and that's a big part of the game
for him he's got good size he goes to the net
he already has a shot on net I thought he was
going to score his first after that power play
expired and he was on the ice with oie very close
to getting it first trus looking for mantha as we
return to the live play little bit shy of the
seven-minute mark man rdik had that one blocked
by Ang Bal Islanders in the traveling whites Paul
Mar looking to clear Ang Bal has a very powerful
skating stride front door there keer made the
save on Nelson and I think the coaching staff
loved that goal in particular they loveed the
fourth guy up in the rush that was a beautiful
shot right up the gut for farari snapshot here
turned away Darcy keer in goal for Washington
in the first quarter plus of the season this is a
set piece for Wilson a backand and styed by varava
kept in by leier tight quarters there for protus
at the line farari dancing with a puck batted at
by Brock Nelson I love the way they're snapping
the puck around turnover here bang bang score
[Applause] leier Nelson a turn turn over
that's a rarity for him picked off and a
beautiful pass right there and you see
that La Pierre shot as fast as possible
good Hustle by mantha a followup there by
protus a three-way goal for the Washington
Capitals to start this game nice back pedal
by laier Barelle Islanders playing without
Matt Martin tonight long slapper borzo
rebound great stop there by keer and he
saved his own bacon here here's the shot
coming off his body the follow up there by
cus the Islanders 158 and8 four better than their
DC Rivals for the moment Washington on the board
first in this game tonight leier from protus
a wraparound attempt fashing he scores Hudson
fashing yeah he used his reach big time in that
puck hit the inside of the pads and skittered
through to the back of the twine here it is around
the wall watch sandine try a little stutter step
there here comes fashing after the good check by
Clutterbuck and he's able to outle Wilson Around
the Net watch Wilson come in for support and he
gets around Wilson and the net Sebastian AO on
the Step Up obey cubel leans in on a push through
move down feeds melen Stein fires rebound at the
doorstep obey cubel not able to deliver there
after he slam the door and stick in The Penalty
Box there's the look watch obey cuel just SL place
it wide on the back end vov didn't even know where
that puck was look at vov he has no clue where it
is he'll drive it hard around the puck belongs to
mantha leier hiding he's got Riley hung up mantha
for an Edmonson bomb he scores Joel [Music]
Edmonson that is a sir from Edmonson his first
capitals goal here it is notice all five are
down protecting the house the puck comes back
and there's the scorching shot protus a big
screen in front not only a screen probably
a shadow because of his size and there it
is no chance for verlof to recover once it gets
past the first Blocker in pal Mar I'm sure they
are doing their best to track amiro schenk's
efforts in this game tonight this one rings
off of keer off the top of the crossbar they got
off and running in the second early on here in
the third starting the same way hit a stick
hit the shoulder hit the crossbar and up in
points and five straight for Nelson who scored
in the first meeting here backhand chance off
the outside of the post camper launching
back sandine helping out too you see the
scramble and they've come out flying here's
that shot ricochets off Ang ball and sandine
gets through camper and there's Ango who can't
collect the rebound and knocked out of Harm's
Way by the hand of sand there's the shot and it
comes through and they can't get it to go keer a
couple of good stops here in this last couple
of minutes against the Islanders rolls it to
Center doson wants the puck lost the handle Mana
closing fires sent it wide here it is the drip
of the Pucket look at how far vam off is out
might have just skimmed off his body but that
shot trying to go faride and there it is Edmonson
curls this pass on the breakout for Jensen and
through Center we go stro with Wilson and oetkin
Alex to the heart of the D lets it Fly llov waved
the goalie sticking blocker at it meaning he's
getting his looks Dylan stro hooks off gets the
puck across Obie follows it up again a rolling
Puck Anders Lee going to the corner farari muscles
up on barzel Lee flattened by Wilson turnover
trouble backhand chance score Anders Lee has
tied [Applause] it a big body with a neet drive
on a broken play right in front of the net it
started with some heavy hitting barzel and farari
really got into it here's the physicality that's
on barzel with barari notice four guys are on one
side here now the puck bu is free Carlson tries to
get it up ice and it actually gets knocked off of
his stick there it comes Lee and it's a forehand
backhand deak and Lee is tied it up with under
eight to go here in the third period Paul Mary
up top buluk fires pinball flipper pad save for
keer on the lead mantha mantha roaring in stopped
there by varlamov Great Stop in front of the net
Anthony mantha sprung by prus pinpoint accurate
passing the seam and pageo down the wing for New
York lobbing this one into the Zone a counter hit
from walstrom centering P peso big save by keer
opportunities the Islanders putting on some Ser
serious heat here's Pano on that redirect and you
described it beautifully on the rotation Carlson
looking to oetkin who just got a new hockey
stick from the bench spot stro stro to a better
shooting angle waights feeds with oetkin up top
snapshot of the way score Dylan stro wins it for
Washington here's the rotation Obie giving it
to stro stro calls his own number and it looked
like it caught the goalie off guard there as
he ripped it past the blocker side one more
look Tom Wilson pretty good screen there but
that was a textbook accurate shot just over
the pad much like Edmonson had over the other
pad stro beats barlam off over the right pad